The Joe Rogan Experience what kind of
blowback oh man you know like uh so much
you know you know I think that um you
know look when we I had Shia LaBeouf on
uh you know
um after these allegations uh came out
of him and um
you know
um being physically and emotionally
abusive to uh to his to his girlfriend
at the time and you know what was crazy
was I I never wanted to have any actors
on that was kind of like my rule just
because and not because there's just so
many podcasts where actors are talking
actors and they're they're talking about
and I'm actually interested in that [ __ ]
but like I you know like nobody needs to
hear me talk about that right but um
Shaya at the time
uh you know he
he was a guy that you know when we did
Fury together
you know that was such a wild experience
and you know he
you know he was this guy who came in he
like pulled his tooth out because he
thought his character shouldn't have a
tooth you know he like cut his his face
you know he didn't shower for eight
months and at first when I met him I was
like this guy's just [ __ ] he's just
loud you know he's just he's he's he's
he's wearing his process on his sleeve
showing everybody how hard he's working
but what I found you know after the
eight months of working with him
with somebody who and I you know and
this is it's just my own and he he is
every bit this thing is every bit as
vital to him as it was with me I found a
real partner I found a real kindred
spirit I found that he was so [ __ ]
cute he was he was willing to risk it
all for for for for this for the work
and I I I walked away with like an
enormous amount of respect for him and
love for him I also saw a guy who grew
up as a child star
um a guy who was
um felt like he needed to bleed out for
his art felt that he needed to live
wildly out on the street and in real
life in order to sort of maintain that
danger in his work and uh I'm coming
from a guy you know me at this point
where I did all that when I I didn't
have the umbrella being you know a big
movie star and I didn't I didn't have
that
but now I'm a guy who's
absolutely a committed husband and
father that that is my life like that
like my life is my family and and what I
found is the the well the things that I
can tap into and my emotional sort of
accessibility of being a dedicated
father and and and and husband is so
much greater than when I was sort of
this wild animal and uh and uh I care
about people way more than I care about
myself my ego is dead in that in that
sense so I really wanted to
be there for him and and the first thing
I remember seeing him and seeing this
like raw nerve and this unbelievable
talent I I I I would say I think he's
the best actor I've ever worked with and
I really wanted to protect him and I
think more than anything else I really
wanted to show him what a real friend
was like I just remember like saying
that to myself I want to show you what a
real friend is like I feel like you've
never really had a real friend and my
friends the guys that I grew up with
um they've been my best friends my whole
life they you know they you know I
couldn't do anything without him I just
like I value that so much right
so we had him on the podcast
um real early on and before this stuff
came out and it was right at a time when
he had gotten in trouble down in um in
in Georgia and he went to rehab and he
wrote this movie sort of about his own
life called honey boy that got nominated
for an Oscar and and he wrote it and he
he started he played his dad it was a
very it's a movie about his life and I
kind of had him on sort of celebrating
you know where he was at because for a
long time he had taken a lot of [ __ ]
from this industry and uh here he was
sort of on top of the world and I
remember at the time you know my my
agents at the time were calling me being
like you you think I could just get a
phone call with shy like maybe we could
like bring him you know just he was like
you know and then these
these uh these chart you know this this
woman said he did these things to him
and he was just he was just done you
know canceled and and
um
and I'll say man when I heard those I
decided when I heard that that he had
done those things
you know for me there really is a red
line with people that I need to look at
with myself and through all the [ __ ]
that I've seen all the [ __ ] that I've
done man I I just I I can't be down with
you if you put your hands on a woman if
you put your hands on a woman or a child
dude I just like you know I can't man I
can't I can't I
can't get over that I can't
and I heard this you know about my
friend and
you know I was really broken-hearted
about it and
time went by I meant like two years and
you know I know how much you know acting
is not only important to him but like
sort of necessary for his survival and I
would reach out on text you know
checking on him and and that but we
hadn't made contact
and then I heard that he was having a
baby
um and uh he was married and I reached
out to him and
um
I said hey man maybe it's time for you
and me to have another talk
and
I made a decision with my team and with
him we're
I needed
again you go back to the intentionality
and and I I really looked at this
this role that you have of being a
friend
and and being a friend is not about
turning your back on somebody when
they're
when they do something that you find
[ __ ] deplorable or when you find
disgusting your job as a friend is to
make sure they don't do it again and
your job now as this guy's being a
father is to to step in there and say
hey man where are you at like what are
you doing what kind of work are you
doing where are you like that's what
being a friend is and everybody in my
life is like the worst idea in the world
you cannot do that you cannot do that
um
and then you know he came on man and and
we spoke and uh
you know I
it was weird because I I found so many
of the same themes and so many of the
same the the heart of what I found in
that elwop Community I found in in Shaya
the level of disgust the level of work
the level of commitment the level of
Shame
the level of uh
time spent
this fluency with with with his victim
and I wasn't I had no interest in
exonerating him or saying or saving him
in any way I wanted to check on him and
I wanted to see how he was doing and I I
felt that that was an honest thing
and
you know just the fact that I had him on
I got you know an enormous amount of of
backlash you know an enormous amount of
uh for the for really the first time
kind of as like a public person just
like kind of hatred
um
and the fact that I had given somebody
who could have you know who may have
done these things that this woman says
you know that that really hurt people
and I felt [ __ ] terrible about that
man like I like did you wish you hadn't
done it no uh no because after talking
to him and then going around and
talking to women
who have been victims himself talking to
you know this one one woman specifically
who we were going to have on but
hurt
she had health issues and couldn't but
you know what what I've found is so many
people have reached out who said like I
was in that place like I I like I was in
that place where he was I was in that
place
where I was whether I was abusive or not
abusive I was getting there and and the
drugs and the alcohol were getting the
better of me and I mean really what you
know he's
he was two years sober at the time that
I had him on and um
and I
thought really what it was was like a
real meditation and shame you know and I
thought that
you know what this woman said to me was
you know with all there's so many places
and platforms
for
women to go to their shelters there's
places to go to to talk about the abuse
to to to be there to help people after
the fact but who is talking to these
[ __ ] up
young men who are committing the abuse
who is talking to them and saying dude
don't do that like I've been there there
is another way this is not the answer
stop go get help change your behavior
work put in the work
I just you know I I I I ultimately felt
you know that that what he said
could have a real positive effect and I
I believe looking back on it now again
man it's like you know what are you
gonna do you can weigh the the the the
comments of people
I've told you you know you're the worst
guy on Earth for doing it or you can
weigh the comments of the people say hey
man I that thing saved my life for you
you know I mean I I can't look at it
that way
I I look at the intentionality behind
what the show was and what why why I
decided to have him on and then why I
decided to air it and I stand by it